on est désolé française a condamné
google ou yahoo il est justement créé
une petite vidéo
il pleurait commencé mon intervention
c'est les premiers pas donc mes premiers
pas sur les hommes et des brèves la
première fois que le rappeur marocain
frauder sur lui au sommet du monde c'est
un mourant qui a changé ma vie et je
voulais partager d'avoir avec nous ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
m
ja
oui
j
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait dès le 28 2013 à peu près
presque trois ans aujourd'hui ça a
changé ma vie parce que j'étais pas
destiné à faire ça j'ai menti
j'ai grandi à gaza j'ai fait toutes mes
études à casablanca
et puis ensuite j'ai intégré une école
de province en france et que ce commerce
de paris et fin 2010 m et puis j'ai une
carrière de financiers pourquoi nos
financiers parce que là les chromes que
quand une école de commerce qui est bien
géré la finance donc nous suivons la
sono est certain on va faire ça et puis
pour être honnête ça permet de payer
pour les pressions et des expéditions à
vendre avant de faire les vôtres
mais j'ai toujours eu un parcours de
sportif depuis très jeune
en fait quand j'étais jeune tous les
sportifs professionnels joué beaucoup au
tennis je rêvais de devenir tennisman
professionnel
malheureusement comme j'étais bon à
l'école que pendant les mois de sites
les blogs pour eux pour
matériel donc j'ai toujours eu cette
frustration et tu peux à l'intérieur de
ne pas faire une carrière sportive et je
me rappelle que dans les années 80 pour
mot les sportifs de l'extrême
c'était le marathonien aujourd'hui
beaucoup de gens ont des semi marathons
des marathons et dans les années 80 se
sont rencontrés un marathonien c'était
resté onze histoires si un jour je perds
à attendre sa hausse à tout ce que j'ai
je suis arrivé je n'ai plus besoin de
rien c'était comme ça un rêve que
j'avais petit à petit j'ai commencé à
m'entraîner j'ai fait des 10 km les
casinos mais un semi-marathon ya vingt
ans j'ai fait mon premier match et
finalement j'ai commencé à développer ce
que j'aurais mérité après laquelle doit
être si tu sais je veux dire si on
al'objectif sur dix préparent on se
donne des moyens
y a rien d'impossible et juste après
l'année d'après j'ai été choisi un très
grand chine au tibet et je suis allé par
hasard au camp de base de l'everest
blessés dont un pillage le tibet et le
népal
donc il ya une impasse de chaque côté et
quand j'étais en - en 2003 j'ai vu des
gens redescendre yeux de l'everest dans
des tenues comme ça avec
leurs combinaisons les masques à oxygène
et choisissez des extraterrestres
impossible doriz arrive jamais je
pourrais faire ça et en fait j'y suis
rappelé que ces extraterrestres fin
septembre à coignières des années 80 et
comme le mamac regard un jour j'ai
réussi à me suis dit tiens pour moi de
moi aussi tenté est tenté d'aller sur
les raisons et j'ai commencé petit à
petit parce qu'on sait pas on this
vallée sur les braises j'exige que aller
step by step
je me suis lancé dans un challenge qui
s'appelle le cente seize sous types
c'est gravir le plus haut sommet de
chaque continent
donc j'ai commencé par laurent que en
2005 su aller au match laissait plus
haut sommet d'amérique du nord
certains masquant de nier serait su
aller à la banque ago et tous à 7 ans
parallèlement travail il était banquier
n'a pas vraiment eu à nous y sommes et
donc à chaque fois que je prenais un
mois un mois et demi et j'allais faire
une expédition est ample et 2012
je me suis dit qu'on ne l'avait pas
encore une idée cette somme est fini il
ya pourquoi ne pas faire des breaks
c'est vrai qu'avec ses symboliques de
porter haut les couleurs du maroc
deux absences 1er et 8 648 même et quand
je me suis lancé ce défi mais beaucoup
choses se sont passées dans ma tête
d'abord on a toujours une petite voix à
l'intérieur aussi j'en ai vraiment qu'un
pas que tu payes ces petites voitures
de lécher france quoi faire des choses
parfois parce qu'on a peur de légers et
du regard des autres
on les sent que présente en athlétisme
dans les années 50 les gens pensaient
que c'était impossible de courir à
mayence et 1600 mètres au moins 4000 en
1953 il ya l'anglais qui a battu le
record s'appelle le rôdeur baptiste
heures la même année quatorze personnes
en voiture report parce que ce verrou
psychologique de ces points possible de
le faire en quatre minutes à sauter et
moi c'était la même chose je préférais
que découvrira moi même si je
réussissais pas mais j'étais sûrement
néanmoins d'autres a aucun frais
auraient suivi des eaux et des forêts
quantenna lâche 2,1 alors j'aime bien
cette phrase des raisins des plus grands
alpinistes américain qui ticketing tout
sauf acquise optionnel tétine damas
manoeuvre est donc allé au sommet est
une option mais redescendre est une
obligation
et pourquoi il dit ça parce que souvent
dans l'année on se trompe dans l'enjeu
d'objection on va peut-être mais c'est
vers certains objectifs est en fête aura
quelques jeux m'ont rappelé le véritable
grand jeu et si vous voulez pour rang en
allant sur les vraies
san jose et dépensez pas d'aller
consommer c'est de rester vivant de
revenir vivante et donc dans cet ange là
un des objectifs
c'était d'arriver au sommet donc
toujours dans la vie réfléchissez à
acquérir au transit qu'est ce que vous
voulez avoir réalisé à 60 70 ans
et puis en fonction de ces enjeux
mettez-vous dans des objectifs qui vont
vers ces vengeurs et si ce n'est pas
paris ajusté cet objectif s'ils ici un
moment je voyais que pour arriver au
sourire je prenais trop de risques le
risque est de combien j'aurais une
changer d'objectif je me serais dit mon
nouvel objectif c'est juste 7500 mais je
suis vite être pour toujours rester
cabinet avec pour l'enjeu c'est
exactement ce que vous pouvez aussi
faire dans votre vie professionnelle et
personnelle alors les traitements les
deux mois pour pour le gravir pourquoi
parce que il ya quelque chose qui est
différent chez sport par rapport aux
autres sports
c'est qu'on est en altitude et si vous
voulez qu'on est sur les braises
on va pas très bien on aura exactement à
ce rythme lent alors vous imaginez de
moi comme ça parce qu'en fait au camp de
base déjà bon que tout redémarre et que
l'expédition la 5300 mètres c'est plutôt
prêt et il ya 50% de l'oxygène que vont
expirer ici donc parfois même à l'arrêt
vous êtes des soufflets et au sommet il
y en a encore un peu de 30%
c'est pour ça que général
cette petite partie en vinyle et 8800 on
utilise des masques à oxygène
parce que l'on appelle ça la zone de
laves ans c'est impossible de rester
plusieurs heures sans oxygène
à ce niveau là et quand j'étais sur les
maïs cette phrase a remarqué je disais
et il y avait cette razzia chinoise tout
cas eu et c'est exactement ça retire un
objectif dont j'étais quelqu'un qui
habite toujours en santé oms de caresser
pour la meilleure école à rennes c'est
pour les meilleurs écrivains poursuivre
ses colonies rogers le mais la meilleure
vie de travail et en finance et j'ai
vraiment pensé après l'émission vous
pouvez je voulais avoir et donc pour
l'enjeu quand est né là bas on a
beaucoup réfléchi pendant ces deux mois
se pendre dans sa forme et j'ai réalisé
que leur mission voulait revoir un
cessez le thermal d'avoir un impact
positif sur les gens qui mentent aux sur
les heures et c'est pour ça que depuis
que sur le human est complètement changé
de 8
j'ai quitté mon emploi en tant que
banquier ma zone de confort et en fait
il n'en est pas vraiment une fois ce que
parfois les gens confondent la zone de
confort avec le confort matériel en
va-t-il mépris maman si vous
réfléchissez bien le bon forcément ça va
à nivelles c'est ça l'état
le confort en fait ce que vous aimez
vous aider dans votre zone de confort
parce que vous êtes scène avec nous
mêmes et ce n'est pas qu'il faut pas
confondre avec le confort matériel qui
est venu gagner de l'argent avoir des
succès des l'importance des valeurs
aussi ses malheurs la vie nous pousse à
nous dépasser et moi c'est quelque chose
qui m'a suivi toute pratique notamment
la forme c'est quelque chose qui m'a
toujours dans les moments forts mons
hainaut les moments difficiles et a
poussé à brest extra man pour dépasser
cc et doute la patrie aussi se sentir le
porte drapeau d'un enfant de personnes
ça peut être familier les chefs de
famille de l'entreprise pays
pourquoi simplement parce que quand vous
voyez que ce que vous réalisez scène ça
ne l'emportera pas du bonheur car une
seule personne mais à plusieurs
personnes à pour vous de vous quand vous
avez encore plus envie pour dépasser
évidemment pluie en
n'en parlons pas des riffs plus vous
dites je perdais passer pour une aisé de
réaliser là moi aussi et enfin appel à
vous moi j'aime bien le petit message
personnel à passion sommet des prêts
vous voulez demander à l'époque m'a
influencé ou au sommet de l'everest
donc c'était vraiment plus la maison
disposera pour y arriver elle a dit oui
[Applaudissements]
l'esprit d'équipé alors souvent la ville
bondissent un sport individuel qui pour
nous voir arriver parfois seul au milieu
de nulle part
non c'est vraiment le score décrit parce
qu'on est en corning donc vraiment
longue vie dépend de l'autre si
quelqu'un glisse vers les autres là pour
le battre a mené des discussions est par
contre ça va réaliser quelque chose que
j'avais peut-être pas mais le monde
professionnel c'est que souvent dans les
équipes ont créé mention aujourd'hui
plus personne
l'alpinisme vous oblige pas rencontrer
avant sur journée - de performance
pourquoi ce que vous avez beau être ravi
des performances il ya quelqu'un de
l'ombre au niveau retière et donc c'est
comme une chienne finalement l'être la
force dit chez vous c'est quoi c'est la
force du maillon le plus faible
vous avez beau avoir pris encore si vous
avez un maillon faible et vous tirez sa
crasse donc parfois il vaut mieux
s'arrêter
essayez désir royaume faire mousser la
fatigue peut-être quand il ya des
difficultés pour avancer plus vite et
vous ferez pas instruite mon argent
thiès pour la boucherie pour vous parce
que s'ils doivent à nicosie règle d'or
ça c'est quelque chose vraiment que
quand j'ai pris conscience
la deuxième chose c'est aussi le rôle du
leader ont décapité d'une équipe de
toujours veiller à ce qu'il y ait des
langes minimum commun parce que chaque
personne dans l'équipe à s'échanger
personnel les personnes va travailler
pour les engins de l'oms met donc c'est
le rôle du leader entre tous ces enjeux
le baiser pour l'interception et le
travail et non sur cet enjeu midi malcom
et nous évidemment c'était arrivé sain
et sauf sur le sommet est de revenir
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure vivent
donc on a tous travaillé alors on se
connaissait pas c'est la première fois
qu'on se croyait en effet kevin aidant
les yankees australiens des américains
mais on a tous travaillé vraiment si on
se connaissait depuis tout le temps
parce qu'on avait cette rangée minimale
commun cet objectif commun pour osciller
aussi une équipe pour épauler rond et
être ouvert aux autres je veux vraiment
et hamilton
à chaque fois que je mets sur ses
expéditions gens mais de la nourriture
marrante et du midi jérôme mai dernier
pleut à très haute avec les eaux en plus
de ces consistant donc je remet souvent
les lots mai
il ya partout on est vraiment c'est ça
va vous aider et en fait de premiers
soins sur les restes j'ai déposé sa sur
la plage et écouter ses très bons c'est
assez conséquente halloween et m'ont
regardé mon silence complet massage
chaque avance qui leur amant perso j'ai
pas très bien compris jetables je
repartis dans ma tendre au lieu de
rester dans cet étalage musique il
demain je vis dans le monde pourquoi ils
bondissent hors de quake on n'avait pas
de mémoire
et ça c'est très important quand elles
perdent la vie différent du vôtre au lui
laisser le moindre essai ni déjà de
comprendre pourquoi il a fait de la vie
du gard parce que pour eux la musique
parfois cette personne a peut-être une
information qu'on a quelqu'un à ce
moment là ou presque il a vécu pareille
situation dans un module et que votre
avis des fans auront donc c'est ce que
j'ai fait de mal et écouté hier une pas
très apprécié et je comprenais pas
parler sans partager et ils m'ont dit on
freine la sauce on a démontré devant
mais c'est parce que si on mange du même
nom si un amour mal à tout le monde
risque de tomber malade et c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose auquel je n'ai
pas réfléchi parce que nous on a grand a
dit m quand tu manges la secousse tu
prends la route et voilà mon essai tout
parce qu'on a
unité de partage et vous vous restez
tolérance 10 dans les jambes que des
priorités draps leurs différends
peut-être là le partage vraiment une
force priorités telles que d'autres
fièvres la sécurité dans en première
priorité et comme le centre ouvert avant
nos priorités pour les secondaires pour
encore une fois un sou des décennies et
les abords des équipes efficient espace
la discipline aussi quelque chose
l ai beaucoup appris à danser dans ses
expéditions
je me rappelle une première expédition
quand j'arrivais elle dans un attentat
près de peter leder de reims tellement
fatigué le lancer avec le 5 ans 5 mois
et je me lançais dans mon sac pour
chaque lot dernier et puis l'après
j'écoutais à voter et j'écoutais les
norvégiens les empiler ressorti de tout
ce qu'ils avaient dans leurs selles dans
les temps et au numérique dans un coin
la nourriture dans un coin et déjà nés
dans le pays mais il perd du temps dans
4-5 vraiment pour eux mais dans cinq et
ils vont redémarrer et ont fait subir
que le monde même quand on était sur un
gros mental
les guides ont demandé de changer dans
les grès norvégien kjetil danse a
exhorté les membres le moins mal que je
siège l'eurobasket
et en fait c'est 180 discipline la
discipline ces mécanismes il faut
discipline dans les petites choses même
les choses qui se bat pour que quand
c'est crucial des 14 est sur une pente à
60° il ya des vents un compte qu'il
aurait bien vous n'êtes pas de compte
chercher vigan et bien là ces
disciplines ravva manière efficace et
c'est tout simple on est des pros c'est
souvent dans l'entreprise c'est un forum
vous emmener mais c'est parce que ces
process un euro contre 1 % américain va
être crucial d'avoir ces procès cela
d'avoir une procession en place la
capacité à s'adapter aussi je pense au
début j'étais très fort de très grands à
massifier télé bref je pense que
physiquement aussi simon pourrait le
faire mais par contre j'ai une capacité
à m'adapter aux conditions qu'ils
chantent dispensant en tant
qu'aventurier mais on sent aussi le
manager dans une entreprise c'est très
important parce que le monde évolue
rapidement alors cela les conditions
climatiques évoluent rapidement et même
dans le monde
entreprise est le tampon mettez en place
une stratégie concurrence il reste pas
les bras croisés
il met aussi en place d'une stratégie
donc cette capacité à s'adapter
rapidement et très importante et c'est
ça qui permet pas aujourd'hui que je me
lance dans les chalets qu'elle n'ait
jamais pensé que ça soit une bonne or
puisque si vous aimez les ferments d'un
marche vers l'étranger de l'année
derrière cette année sereine au pôle sud
c'est parce que c'est devenu si vous
voulez pour moi je changement des
panneaux menace et une opportunité et ça
c'est important de voir le changement
comme une opportunité
c'est ce qui fait que souvent j'entends
parfois les gens dire tram ils attachent
ans qui était au volant de ronron mais
pour être au bon endroit en plus vous
êtes t1 qui s'adapte rapidement qui
régime qui veut changer de communion de
changer de job vivement de changer de
file il est toujours le premier pardon
mais statistiquement il ya plus de
chance d'être au bon endroit au bon
moment
alors les nous évidemment l on a tous
ces mots en bouche loramyc en personne
est motivé comme salarié est en timide
hausse des moments très motivé lui des
moments de l'art
et puis savons pas moi je me rappelle
quand j'étais étudiant
poster dans ma chambre il sait quand le
bon dieu pour fermer portes et j'ai
toujours dans ces moments difficiles je
cherche la fenêtre est en cours il perd
il faut juste rester assez fermé vers
ans et à prendre avant de repartir et
des gens d'un autre chose disait que
pour masser 10h40 landes lfb a inventé
en continuant à tignes avec qui c'est y
multiples finalement différentes
vous imaginez c'est à fait légitime ivre
il a réussi une fois la dernière
et pour ça y est encore produit 200
entrées dont qq soit le nombre des chefs
de dire que vous aurez n'aura ni les
staffs faisons laurie pratique mais qui
suffit de vous laisser une seule fois la
dernière pour que vous ayez réussi et ça
ça devrait pour mentir et à toujours
persévérer à se dire quel que soit ce
qui est déjà passé il suffit qu'on
réussisse la dernière chose pour pour
vous pour y aller alors le soutient
évidemment le soutien des proches ça
s'arrête à passer ces moments difficiles
roi y avait une super campagne sur les
réseaux sociaux de gens qui
m'encouragent et de marocains du monde
entier qui m'a envoyé des messages et ça
ça m'a vraiment
poussés à le dépasser
et puis je voulais me dire quoi ce quel
que soit ce qu'on a réalisé dans sa vie
forrest et nan parceque on a sûrement
une chance parfois de démarquer d'autres
maillots
j'ai été traitée prenez marocain pierre
houde rare en plein dans la région
d'odienné est toujours pas elle aurait
pu faire les dres ils ont peut-être pas
eu les moyens de le faire où il vit on
va penser peut-être mais donc rester
dans ces conditions là pour les
conditions climatiques aussi je sais pas
si vous avez vu depuis deux ans il y
avait des tremblements terre a sonné par
une avalanche en 2014
il ya eu beaucoup de gens il était très
brillant qui ont essayé ces deux années
et si gilles et j'aurais peut-être
j'aurais sûrement l'impression je
n'aurais pas réussi puisque personne n'a
réussi ces deux années il y en a qui
sont membres
d'ailleurs pour la petite histoire il ya
une marocaine s'est inquiété au sur les
vraies celles charles j'espère été
l'année dernière elle a pas réussi à
poser des conditions climatiques et
j'espère que cette année elle elle
pouvait être serons nous l'avons
conditions soient si quand on réalise
quelque chose évidemment on est on est
content d'être reconnu pour ce qu'on a
réalisé
mais je voulais venir un message sur la
renaissance
c'est très important pour que votre
reconnaissance et alphonse qu'elle se
fasse au moment où quelqu'un a réalisé à
l'export et j'ai été très honoré de
recevoir les
mais sa prestation sa majesté le jour où
je suis arrivé au sommet et ça ça va
beaucoup poussé parce que ça montre
qu'on suivait ce qu'on faisait kerry une
certaine attention pour ce qu'on faisait
et c'est par an ça va ça n'a pas la même
valeur que rencontre la collecte
commence mais après dans un couloir dans
une conférence mis à la rue avec le mois
dernier qui a fait un truc bravo non il
faut que vous preniez mois de romance et
se connecte à réaliser quelque chose et
que vous la plier devant le féliciter
l'a félicité là ça prouve que vraiment
vous avez le sens pratique et l'empathie
vraiment une des qualités de leader et
sa fille fait que ben cette personne a
encore envie de se dépasser encore plus
pour vous là sa prochaine fois j'ai
aussi une petite partie de l'année sa
majesté pour dire aussi la
personnalisation des messages importants
je ne reconnaissais pas le travail qu
apprendre d'un collègue avec un message
standard que vous enviez la cumo parce
que encore une fois vous ferez preuve
d'empathie vont entraîner que pour
réaliser tous les forfaits cette
personne là m'a mis dans ce travail note
et finalement pour le pack très long
ces phrases je trouve les hydra c'est
bien
mon parcours travers la langue
originelle il faire ses cadences
extraordinaire on peut tout obtenir
je les vois jouer pour faire des breaks
se produit la première fois la droite il
ya vingt ans donc je suis pas belle la
vie diffusé les rendements des jeunes
avaient jamais plus de trains que les
travaux avant le très beau au tibet mais
par contre je viens très persévérant
comme on dit chez nous on sera quand je
veux quelque chose je me barre pour y
arriver et j'essaie de tout faire et en
fait il ya pour affronter cette dernière
histoire c'est qu'on a vraiment marqué
dans ma vie j'avais 5 ans je regardais
la télé délits en moins des blancs et je
regardais les jeux olympiques de 1984 et
pour la première fois un attrait
marocains arabes musulmans gagner une
médaille d'or olympique
en fait c'était une feinte des roues
motorisés et ça m'a beaucoup touché par
smith mais aussi en tant que le mans en
terre on peut réaliser des choses en
tira peut battre les années
moi c'était extraordinaire de pathé à
qualité et quand des minéraux l entrée d
chanter l'hymne national sur le podium
olympique
ça m'a touché et ça m'a marqué et je me
suis dit j'ai envie fuir le même monde
mon rêve c'est d'aller aux jeux
olympiques et de chantier du national
sur un point du relais et je me suis dit
super coq faire dans ma vie pour y
arriver
j'ai commencé par le tennis et la taxe à
pied des triathlons de poudre ou à 32
ans dans l'année sur les vraies équipes
en la salle même si j'ai quelqu'un qui
croit que quand on aime on peut y
arriver
à 39 ans sans risquer d'être un petit
peu dur pour les oled mais je suis dit
non je vais continuer une croix on sait
jamais les règles du jeu peuvent changer
il peut y avoir un nouveau souvent entre
jeux d'aller à l'école je crois qu'il
revienne au jeu les servettiens
problèmes d'il ya 50 ans et d'ailleurs
pour vous projeter comme ça dans la
vraie vie de vous projeter déjà fait
avec
du jeu d'aujourd'hui parce que les
règles du jeu changent voisine d'en
rester toujours au près et je me suis
non je vais continuer à prendre en
charge la journée ce moment là un sme
sais pas quand je suis revenu vers
l'ouest et le beaucoup de gens qui
m'attendent et à la grevant défi sortie
de l'avion
des gens m'ont portée et tous les
aéroports a commencé à chanter l'hymne
national
donc finalement s'aiment et se
respectent français n'allait jamais
arrivé a fini par arriver parce que j'y
ai cru alors peut-être pas exactement de
la façon que je ne m'attendais c'est
urgent de l'ennemi mais ça aussi quand
vous avez
gardez les yeux ouverts regarder des
signes par poignées de mains exactement
de la façon vous voulez par la grève du
lait mais ils seront ils arrivent non
c'est quand même lourd en fait il y
avait quand même moment pour vous lancer
dans l'univers univers on rendra
toujours votre bon grand gars au même
endroit la seule personne qui vous
empêchera de rattraper simonet c'est
qu'un monstre est fatiguée maintenant
épuisé ou six réponses et
mais si vous réussissez au même endroit
le programme finira toujours par revenir
mais vraiment ça se sache ça se joue
avec nous mais il faut pas trouver des
excuses à ce tir alors emparé à brax
s'était pas les bonnes conditions il ya
peu nous on est responsable des choix
que l'on fait dans sa vie
quels que soient les joueurs même le
joint de ne rien faire et acheminement
puis je dire sur ce proverbe chinois
quand tu arrivée au sommet de la
montagne continue de grave ne s'est
jamais fait d'erreur on sort ça y est je
suis arrivé c'est chaque objectif
finalement et qu'un nouveau les aubaines
on avait un objectif plus ambitieux et
j'espère que vous aussi vous irez vers
moi trés bref m
[Applaudissements]